the
realm do you know what the realm
is it's the Thousand Blades of agon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a
lie all right my friends once again we
have another Winds of winner update from
the one and only George R Martin as you
all know the WIS of winter will be the
next novel and Author George R Martin's
A Song of Ice and Fire Saga fans have
been waiting to read this novel ever
since HBO released its first season of
Game of Thrones all the way back in 2011
now I think it's safe to say some of us
are even more excited to read it because
we hope it will have a better ending
than what we saw on the show
unfortunately some of us have been
waiting for its release for well over a
decade if you watch all my videos then
you know I always make a new one
whenever George R Martin gives us an
update on its status I recently made a
video where I read every single Winds of
winner update from George R Martin
for over a dozen years we've heard him
say he's only about a year away from
actually finishing it in fact one of his
most recent updates revealed he's now
over three4 of the way done as you can
imagine this had fans very excited
because it finally felt as if the Finish
Line was in sight for once he finally
gave us some insight into how much he's
actually written over all these years I
mean hell even I started to think we
might see the ons of winner sooner
rather than later well once again I'm
not so sure about that during George R
Martin's most recent interview he said
something that makes me think it might
still be years before we ever see it
he's now gone back to criticizing his
fans who will not shut up about the
release date for the wins of winter I
mean you all know it's no secret A Song
of Ice and Fire fans have been demanding
his novel ever since he's missed
deadline after deadline although I am
sure it does get annoying he was the one
who always said it would be out the very
next year obviously this has had fans on
the edge of their seat anxiously
awaiting for its release well in his new
interview he said I've been working I'm
12 years late with the Winds of Winter
I'm just going to put it right out there
you guys don't have to pester me about
it so how many how many uh you know I've
been working I'm 12 years late with
Winds of Winter as we know I'm I'm just
going to put it right out there you guys
don't have to pest for me about it now
maybe it's only me but it sounds like
someone who's frustrated because he
knows he still has a lot of work to do
before he can finish it I say that
because someone who's almost done would
have said don't worry it will be out
very soon the demand would not bother
someone who's ready to deliver again
maybe I'm the only one who feels this
way but I think he's upset because he
knows he's still not ready to release it
even after all these years now I want to
ask all of you this who do you think is
more annoyed by it the writer who can't
finish it or the fans who still haven't
been able to read it after they were
assured they would have it 5 years ago
unfortunately there's no real winners on
either side he's still writing and we're
still waiting there are are definitely
some fans who need to relax with how
they demand the ons of winter he's not
able to say anything even about his
friends who have passed away without
having a thousand fans Hound him about
the damn novel what makes all of this
worse is knowing that the Winds of
Winter will not have the ending to A
Song of Ice and Fire it will be filled
with amazing chapters from front to back
but we still won't know how the story
ends if it's taking him over a decade to
write the Winds of Winter you have to
wonder how long it will be before we
ever see a dream of spring and I hate to
be the guy to say it but I don't think a
dream of spring will have the full
ending either I don't believe he will be
able to finish the massive story in only
seven novels the only way I see that
happening is if he does what the show
did and that's having everyone speedrun
around the entire map to get where they
need to be in time for the final battle
against the White Walkers and the army
of the dead as of right now they're all
scattered into the wind in different
locations throughout Westeros and Os it
will be very difficult for some of them
to make it the Westeros before the end
of the ons of of winter some of them are
nowhere near ready to make that Journey
assuming they will need to be there to
face the white walkers that's one reason
why I'm worried he will have to divide
the novel in halves like he did with A
Feast for Crows and to Dance with
Dragons he's already gone on record
saying this will be the biggest novel
he's ever written and I'm sure it hasn't
been easy for him and finally you asked
a question I knew I was going to get do
you have an
update on the Winds of Winter
um you know it's the same update I
giving for a long time I'm I continue to
work on
it it continues to get longer and longer
I mean I was working on it the day
before I flew back here for three or
four days but I
was I was rereading some chapters that
I'd written earlier and I didn't like
them well enough and uh so I kind of
ripped them apart and rewrote them um
and I've had some ideas while I've been
on this trip I got to get back and and
hopefully get to it while the ideas are
still fresh in my head um it's a big big
book I've said that before it's a
challenging book
um it's probably going to be a larger
book than any of the pre previous
volumes in the series uh
the the um Dance with Dragons and Stor
of Swords are the two largest books in
the series they were both about 1,500
manuscript pages I think this one is
going to be longer than that by the time
I finish it and I think I'm about 3/4 of
the away done maybe um but that's not
100% done so I I have to continue to
work on
it now I want to show you what some of
the fans had to say after they saw what
George R Martin said in the recent
interview as you can imagine some of
them were not happy about what he had to
say Zach said he still has another novel
to write after this one and he's already
75 years old and what time do we become
concerned that he will never finish the
series this received over 5,000 likes
then Rick said I would rather him be
honest and say he doesn't want to finish
it Tristan said he's gone from saying
any moment now to just a few more years
just you wait to 5 years tops I swear
but now he's saying yeah yeah I know
shut up stop asking me about it this one
had 5,000 likes as well the dawn said
it's obvious he's lost interest in his
own story Ian albas said George R Martin
will definitely use Chad GPT to finish
writing his Saga now that's actually
kind of funny considering George R
Martin is involved in a lawsuit against
AI writing software don't worry I won't
get into all of that here though I just
thought some of you would like to know
how he feels right now whatever you do
don't ask him about the WIS of winner
let him know you would rather have
another coffee table book or volume Five
of Fire and Blood I'm sure he has Linda
and Alo on standby anyways let me know
what you think about the recent
interview he might not have said a lot
but I do think it speaks volumes as
always I want to thank all of you for
watching another video I hope everyone
has a great day I will see you again
very soon
[Music]
bye
go